halloween
it's ice time yeah i thought you could
get a head start on heist prep
good luck i'm already dressed well
i'm also dressed and i made breakfast
wait where are my eggs in my belly yeah
now get a move on it's heist time
good morning boyle it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume i was going to sir but then i
decided
screw that jazz well i'm the only one
who ever dresses up
no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so i'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
charles seriously no costume what the
hell charles where's your halloween
spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have
never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume
does it matter if i say no
[Music]
why are you dressed up you look like an
idiot but yeah what are you supposed to
be
a sassy car mechanic no come on he's
clearly the rejected pop-tarts mascot
harry pop-tart i
am not you know who i am squad that's
enough
you're making boyle football on purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater can't see the tow truck
anymore
charles how come you're so much slower
than a car well i'm just trying not to
jost you too much
you're the champagne of friends look
there's part of a bed
maybe we can get a cab up there there's
still time to get that watch all right
excuse me excuse me shoelace cop coming
through
jake where are you come on
i was gonna wear this jacket to my
cousin's butt mitzvah next week
get off of me party bus
get on board good idea boys
nypd i won't stop the party but i do
need the bus
all right what is happening here it's
halloween
man it's halloween
halloween well gotta do something for 16
blocks
hey jake can we talk
you really hurt my feelings by leaving
me off your team oh
i had no idea you felt that way well it
doesn't feel great to be left out
right totally i get it i'm sorry captain
holt
what why are you yelling at my boob
because that's where the camera is
nice try ray ray there's no camera jake
i was being serious
okay fine if you're telling the truth
then i sincerely
apologize but since you're not i will
defeat you
yeah scary witch scary so scary looks
like we're all clear
good job guys nothing can stop this
[ __ ] train
boyle stop finding variations on a word
we hate okay sarge lift up the super
heavy thing that no one else is strong
enough to lift
nice sarge keep lifting heavy stuff like
that maybe you'll work off some of that
bulk huh what
i set up an electric eye yesterday so if
anyone enters this room an alarm will go
off
let's move don't cross the beam
cool yeah that's something i can do
without any problem
alarm works sir do you have a minute
of course jeffords will rendezvous later
sir i want to talk about jake okay amy
hell
our foot fungus heist has gone sideways
hitchcock not now
scully doesn't know i'm in here i stole
his foot cream but then i lost it
amy you're the only hope i have of
finding it you're a detective
you're a detective get out of here
go sir
jake really pissed me off and i want to
help you take him down
well that's an intriguing proposition
you certainly could be useful
thank you to jake
i gotcha peralta you're not fooling
anyone
why does everyone think that's where a
camera would be because the cleavage
cloaks the camera with its
curves that'll be all spy
sorry i said cleavage this year's
halloween heist is a three-way
tiebreaker to determine the champion of
champions we'll be playing for this
a plaque that reads the ultimate
detective slash genius
you and santiago should quit now i'm
going to stomp on your dreams it's fun
to see you so passionate
i will slit you both open from mouth to
anus and wear you like jackets
huh is it weird that that turned me on a
little bit so where on gina's mobile
should i place this
moonless jupiter i pity the child who
lies beneath this
solar system hey captain something's
going on with this heist
you tell us everything you know and
we'll tell you everything we know
i'd rather not ah joke's on you we don't
know anything well
good day then wait why are you sweating
i'm not sweating oh i've had enough
heart attacks to know what sweating
looks like
not sweat
[Music]
well if i'm sweating as you claim it's
because i was watching an exciting video
on the net
really what it was a video of an
american
gymnast his leotard ripped exposing his
butt
highly erotic you're lying i.t just
installed blocker software
thanks to moi uh yes but they didn't
install it on my computer because
i'm a captain you don't look hot and
bothered at all to me show us the
erotica
gentlemen i assure you there's nothing
to see now if you'll excuse me
i have to grab some fresh air
good boy cheddar bring me that caramel
[Music]
wait a minute this isn't the
championship cummerbund
this is some common cummerbund
you're not cheddar this is some common
[ __ ]
where are you coming from why do you
care thought you weren't heisting
i'm not i'm just interested in your
comings and goings because i care about
you as a friend
okay friend i went to the bathroom well
you were gone a long time friend
you feeling okay friend no it was number
two and it was very intense
friend bless you
she sneezed dog allergies which means
that
amy took shut up
where is my dog aren't you standing
right next to him
this [ __ ] please watch jake
jake idiot i know
one of you took cheddar and you did it
for the sake of the heist but if
anything happens to him i
will end you i couldn't bring myself to
neuter cheddar but i
will neuter you all
er bingbot thanks for coming back bill i
really needed a teammate
hey man you're paying no you can
take the wig off if you want whatever
you want man you're paying cause you
stop saying that bill it's making me a
little uncomfortable all right man it's
your money
that's the same thing this is so
frustrating there's no way of knowing
who has the plaque hey man rosa have it
what how do you know
diaz usually favors her left leg but
after zero dark pizza she was suddenly
favoring her right
yes yes which means that she
was
you trailed off and didn't finish
speaking continue
i don't want to her gate was thrown off
because she was carrying the plaque
and i know exactly where it's hidden in
santiago's secret
cigarette stash how did you find that
whenever she gets stressed out
she smokes and it's almost too easy to
stress around
oh santiago i
[Music]
never mind what is it what
[Music]
ping pong and now it's time to send in
our cute little secret weapon
i'm ready captain i love the nickname no
charles not you
i was talking about cheddar oh right
obviously
over the past month i've had him trained
to retrieve plaques and now boy
it's time to make daddy proud yes sir i
could not have been more clearly talking
to the dog
amy santiago will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
i love you so much hey jerkos this
little [ __ ] escaped so that ought to
teach did you just mm-hmm
and did you say mm-hmm
you